SPEAKER: Service Level
Objectives, or SLOs,
are the primary way by which
we set appropriate reliability
targets for our services.
The latest release of SLO
monitoring in Google Cloud
operations makes doing this
especially easy for services
running on GKE.
I'm here today to give you
a walk through and show you
how to get started.
This is The Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We looked at how to use the
API to define Service Level
Indicators, or SLIs and set
SLOs in an earlier episode.
But now, you can do
both of those in the UI.
Let's take a look.
Start by going to the Services
screen under Monitoring.
If you were using the Istio
service mesh in your cluster,
you'll notice that your services
have already been automatically
identified for you.
You can filter the
list as necessary.
For example, you
may want to only see
services running in
a particular cluster
or in that particular region.
To filter for services that
match a particular label value,
just type the value of the label
you want into the Filter field.
If you're not using Istio,
you can define a new service
by selecting a GKE
entity you'd like to use
as the base for the service.
This won't make any
modifications of the entity
itself, it'll just create
a new monitoring construct
you can use to create SLOs.
Once you've found the
service you're looking for,
or created a new one,
click on it in the list.
On the Service
Detail screen, you
can see the SLOs you've already
defined for it, if there
are any, any alerts for
the time span selected,
and the logs for the service.
From here click Create SLO.
In order to create
an SLO, you first
have to choose the SLI, or
the Service Level Indicator,
you'd like to use as the
measure of service reliability.
Here you have three options:
availability, performance,
or other.
But what does each
one of those mean?
An Availability SLI
will measure the ratio
of successful requests to
all request of the service.
For this service,
Istio automatically
tracks that metric and no
additional instrumentation
is necessary.
A Performance SLI
will measure the ratio
of requests that complete
within a specific time
to all requests.
Because Istio automatically
tracks latency
for each request, this is
another out of the box metric.
If you want to use a
custom metric as your SLI,
select Other at this point.
For example, you may have
instrumented the service
using OpenTelemetry to count
the number of transactions
that meet specific criteria.
Using a custom SLI will
let you select that metric.
The next choice is
between a Request-based
and a Window-based SLI.
We covered this in
our earlier episode
on using the API to create
SLOs, but it's worth
reviewing it briefly.
Request-based SLIs
measure the fraction
of good units of work
against the total.
Now for example, what percentage
of requests of your service
were successful in
a given time window?
An example of a
Request-based availability
SLO is 99% of requests are
successful over a rolling seven
day window.
This is the more
straightforward,
and commonly used, option.
Window-based SLIs measure the
fraction of time intervals
during which the service meets
some threshold over a given
time window.
An example of a
Window-based availability
SLO is 99% of requests
are successful within 99%
of 10 minute intervals over
a rolling seven day window.
Once you've selected your
SLI and evaluation type,
click Next.
Take a look at the
signal you've chosen
and confirm that the metric
behaves as you would expect.
For example, if the service has
been healthy for the last hour
the metric should show
a mostly flat trend.
Once you're satisfied with
the signal, click Next.
You may recall that an SLO
is the combination of three
things: the SLI, which
we've already chosen,
a target, and a
compliance period.
On this screen, you need to
provide the compliance period,
which is the length
of the time window
over which the SLI is
going to be evaluated.
Next, specify your goal.
This is the target for the SLI.
Now your SLO
definition is complete.
Click Next to finalize it.
This is the last
step: give your SLO
a name that reflects what it's
measuring, and click Submit.
That'll take you back to
the Service Detail screen
with your new SLO added and
its health clearly displayed.
Thanks for joining me today.
We looked through the new
SLO monitoring functionality
and learned how to use
it to define availability
and performance SLOs for
our services running in GKE.
Now you are ready
to start configuring
SLOs for your own services.
Thanks for watching and
come back soon for more.
This is The Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.